so chris what do you do with the khan
academy i'm a software engineer at the
khan academy and what is what does that
mean what in particular do you focus on
every day i focus on
i guess creating parts of the software
platform that underpins khan academy and
what software is there in khan academy
oh there's so much software iconic
we have we have mobile applications uh
on your ipad we've got um you know
what you know is the website that access
it through the browser we have the code
that runs all all of kind of the data
that we have and and the platform itself
i mean i mean khan academy
at core right is is this content but the
there's kind of this hidden piece which
is you know how do you get the content
it just doesn't exist you know just
unattached to anything and that's you
know the code platform and so yes uh a
big part of what we do is is code when
like a student comes in how do you know
what problems to get how do you know the
student got it right or wrong or how
long it took them and then what do you
give them next and what suggestions you
make and ryan keeping track of all that
for millions of people yeah not only
that but just how do you get it to a
student so when you when you visit the
site you know how does that how does
that get to you you know that's all
software and how do they find it right
how do you find it yeah when you when
you search for it you know whether it's
through us or through somewhere else
it's not just the website it's now
mobile apps and things like that as well
that's right yep yep
and so what's your what's your
day-to-day like right so my day-to-day
is
let's see so i will i will come in and
figure out you know
where i am where did i last leave off on
a project that i'm working on right and
these these kind of projects are these
these uh things we have with the goal of
you know we want to allow something to
happen on the side or fix some problem
that we've recognized before and you
know we forgot the set of steps what
does it take you know what do i have to
do to change the software this
description of you know how things work
um to get kind of to that end goal and
so then you know i
have a plan and i pick up where i left
off and i'm working inside so often to
do that it's um
you know it might be
digging into and discovering uh how
areas of the code behave that i haven't
been in before to kind of gain an
understanding of you know what's
happening under the hood and once i've
got that i can think about you know how
do i change that or or what is missing
that needs to be there to support what
it is that i'm trying to do
uh and then i will actually you know
then go in and build that and you know
maybe it'll be a bit of prototyping you
know trying a few different approaches
and seeing what makes the most sense if
especially if it's an area i'm
unfamiliar with um
or
you know maybe something i really know
well and i know exactly kind of where to
surgically get in there and and make
some changes and who do you typically
work with
so
i i suppose
i work with whoever happens to be on my
project and the typical people i guess
are other kind of people who work on the
back back end systems that we work with
mostly other engineers usually
yeah the a lot of the projects that i do
are kind of uh
for to support engineering um also on
the site so it's my kind of
you know when you think of
delivering something people talk about
you know who's my customer or who's you
know the person that i'm building this
for and for me often it's another
developer and so you know when i work
with someone might be collaborating with
someone to actually build something or
it might be talking to someone to figure
out how they use something that i'm you
know trying to fix it could be something
to empower them to be for them to
develop something faster or for whatever
for whatever application or code they're
deploying to just be more performant and
scale better and whatever else right
that's right yeah
and what were you doing before khan
academy before khan academy also
software
as you might imagine uh so
prior to khan academy uh directly i was
uh at uh yahoo a large internet company
yes um working on yahoo.com
yeah that's really maybe you have yahoo
mail um right so i was working there and
i was doing also you know i was doing
engineering there's a different style
that was more of this kind of front-end
engineering um which is you know a code
that's more likely to run you know right
on your web browser when you visit the
site like directly interact with the
user right directly
interact with users see more user
interaction and then interfacing with
the kinds of things that i'm working
more on writing now yeah the front end
interacts with the user and then also
interacts with the backend which sort of
interacts with the
database right the database or other
backend services or other other things
yeah it's the intermediary and what what
brought you to khan academy
right so
i mean i've kind of always been
interested in in education something uh
you know the steered me i enjoy learning
various things and you know often all
around software you know what what do i
like spending my time on well oh this
new thing is very interesting to know
about or getting more in-depth with
something i already know um
and
you know that's kind of always been a
thing for me
and when i heard about khan academy uh
and viewed some of the videos i was like
wow this is this i felt like i did a
really good job of kind of communicating
the intuition behind some of these and i
was looking at some of the math content
behind some of these mathematical
concepts i'm like wow you know i really
wish i had explored uh that mathematical
concept in that way i can't remember
which exactly it was maybe it was around
statistics oh yeah yeah and and kind of
develop this intuition for it
instead of you know okay here are the
the theorems that i'm used to here are
the rules and then trying to okay apply
these rules that i have no feel for um
to do and i was like well that's really
that's very different that's very
groundbreaking i wish i had that you
know that's something i really want and
i want other people to have that too um
and that was a big reason why i want to
be a part of building this out i thought
it would be really valuable kind of for
for everybody and you've been at khan
academy for what
over three years over three years yeah
yeah so almost from i mean you know
because i've been operating out of
closet for almost 10 now but we didn't
get office space until about four and a
half years so almost from the beginning
of being a real organization and i mean
what's what's been a lot what's it been
like what's been surprising about it
sure
well it's been it's been a wonderful
experience um
you know having having been here i mean
being able to
kind of uh
well there are many different aspects to
unpack here so so being somewhere where
i you know really care about the mission
of what it is that we're doing and it's
something that i you know personally
want to have an impact on and change and
bring to people um
you know there's no there's no point at
which i get up in the morning and i say
well so have we brought you know have we
brought education to the world oh yes
that's done okay time to move on right
it's like nope yep i'm doing that i'm
working on that and that's you know
that's incredibly important so it's very
exciting right getting out of bed in the
morning and coming into work on this um
and
uh
you know so that that aspect's been
wonderful and then kind of the
co-workers who i've i've been working on
these people that i've gotten to know uh
it's pretty great i find that that you
know people who wind up being here have
are very interested in it you know you
don't just choose it and being a
nonprofit right you don't just choose
this out of nowhere you're like all
right
you know where am i going to you know i
don't know build the next high equity
you know
company well you know in a non-profit
i'm going to do that no that's not quite
the thing you think about what what's
what am i doing what am i creating
what's the mission you know what do i
want to change and we've got to i feel
like we've got a really
kind of good take on actually having an
impact and i mean i mean
i've seen this over the past few years
as we've gotten larger and become more
well-known and you know uh and then just
constantly the influx of you know people
who whose lives we've impacted is is is
pretty amazing so
that's it
i agree that gets me up too and and what
are you excited about right now
right uh
let's see
i think
i think that i really like uh
this kind of
uh direction that we've got of kind of
meeting people where they are has kind
of been this thing we've been talking
about a lot you know how do folks get
the most you know value out of kind of
commitment how do we touch their lives
directly um
and so this this kind of idea of you
know figuring out you know how how is
this most valuable
to you and you know as a person visiting
the site and uh using the resources and
how do we kind of
use that uh as inroads to
uh just i mean more more value more
interest i mean when you when you i feel
that when you
uh
see this you know like for me when i see
oh this concept presented in this way is
is very interesting and i like that oh
isn't that fascinating you kind of want
to say well what what else
what other things am i you know do i am
i missing a model here for or is there
some neat aspect to it yeah i can get
some extra feedback and personalize to
me
yeah no i'm with you right yeah and then
that yes
pick what you're looking for yeah well
thank you so much uh and it's been it's
been fun and honored to be to have you
part of this team oh it's been an honor
to be part of you know so i'm very glad
to have have come across this and
they've been a part so thank you so
thank you